the first month of january 2014 has gone
by very quickly
and
i didn't get quite as much done as as
usual as i would have liked to but i
actually got quite a lot accomplished
especially given that i spent
oh about a good week out of the the four
available weeks
being sick with some sort of flu that
was going around
and now that i actually sort of charted
out i see that i did in fact get quite a
bit
if not done at least on the way to being
done perhaps this month got a lot of
exciting things coming up in february
and i'll talk about those in a few
minutes
a little bit of review about what i
intended to get done in january when i
actually got done in january um there
were a few things that i didn't intend
to work on that i actually did work on
so i suppose that's a good thing
i guess the the first big thing is
classes and at this point in my
work um i've got my face-to-face classes
and online classes that i do with marist
as an adjunct there
i've been this is my third year now
working for marist
and i've also got these these online
platforms that i'm getting more and more
involved in and
there are ways for
somebody who's sufficiently
entrepreneurial
and who's got a good you know
presence and rapport with students and
who knows how to use the technology to
their advantage to actually perhaps
be able to teach some some
classes they ordinarily wouldn't get to
teach and to make some some money in the
process so it's a possibility for me to
actually
make a living at doing this this sort of
thing
so i've got the the marist classes i i
was teaching an online ethics class a
very intensive four-week class
and that straddled december and january
as a matter of fact the bulk of the
class was actually in january
it was officially four weeks but it was
really five weeks
a lot of work in that class um i didn't
have to develop a lot of new resources
because i've been teaching these these
ethics classes including online ethics
classes for a while but you always have
to like go in and make sure that the
course shell is all set up properly
there's always some things that need to
be tweaked
dates need to be changed you know
sometimes i like to switch up the order
of what we're what we're studying and i
like to keep the assignments kind of
fresh as well
but i had a ton of grading just a ton
because you know
imagine you're compressing a 16-week
class into
four to five weeks and in a normal
16-week ethics class i'm going to have
my students write
10 short reflection papers i'm going to
have them do anywhere from six to eight
cases that are like three to five pages
each
and i might have them do some some
additional work and with with this
online class not only do we have all
that writing to do
um
there's also forums because the only
interaction
that we really have we don't have a
face-to-face classroom obviously i use
my videos
in that a course in ethics playlist
to
give the students
the experience of like face-to-face
classes that they would normally have
and a lot of them find it very helpful
but the the actual discussion that
really has to take place for student
learning to to can be consolidated
happens through these discussion forums
and i got to go in and read all this
stuff and respond to it so it you know
it was a good you know
anywhere from two to four hours a day
uh in on on this this class online
sitting in front of the computer and
that ended on the 17th
and then you know i had that weekend to
get grading done and then that that
tuesday immediately afterwards it was
face-to-face classes
so of course the first day of class is
you know handing out the syllabus and
going over expectations and finding out
what the students know but then we
jumped into
uh
aleister mcintyre in my ethics class and
we jumped into discussion about what
religious studies was about in my
religion in america class and those are
the two face-to-face classes i've got
going on this semester so i'm on campus
uh two days a week
kind of long days those days because i
do the two classes and i also do my
office hours and any other meetings with
students that i need to do
and i'm doing ethics i i wanted to do
something really innovative with it and
and do what they call flipping the
classroom but that that just didn't
happen in part because i was i was sick
and that took away from my my prep time
so i'm teaching the ethics class relying
on all the resources that i've got
available i've got to say it's going
really well
this this class of students are are very
given to discussion
i'm having a great time with them
the religion in america class is a
class that used to be a staple class for
me when i taught for ball state because
i was teaching philosophy and religious
studies
and
not a ton of things have changed in the
religious landscape of america and the
religious history of america but a few
new things are on the horizon so you
always have to like revise your research
and i'm you know i'm developing this
back then i thought it face to face and
i actually had a lot of handouts and
actually overhead projector uh images
and then i didn't teach it for a while
and now i'm teaching it again and i'm
using this online setting to to really
give the students a lot of material and
access to documents
resources you know i'm writing
handouts and and lessons for them so
that's that's taking quite a bit of time
as well and i'm enjoying that class
i'm using a textbook that takes a sort
of grand historical view through it so
it doesn't take
uh denominations and and go through
their entire existence from from
beginning to end it kind of tells
portions of the story along the way so
that's a bit of a challenge
as far as designing the course but
it's not bad and i'm videotaping that
course
so if you've been following um you know
the feed of my my videos you know that
there's these religion and america
lectures that are coming through and i
decided instead of making them an entire
class session i would
make them a certain amount of material
usually a chapter but although some of
the chapters in this book are rather
short so they i may roll a couple
together
so um
that's that's part of what's been going
on
other course work i am still in the
process of developing a a course for
opperno a course on existentialist
philosophy and literature
and i'm having a lot of fun with that
that's in a different course management
system called canvas
and a plano is doing something really
innovative i think actually they've got
some some courses that will be coming
out
if they're not out already very soon
and aplerno
is offering courses
for credit
that students
sign up for
pay for they have a certain amount of of
online contact hours with the professor
so you have these uh these video
meetings with them
i'll probably do mine using you know my
chalkboard and my my normal environment
using my laptop
and
it's brilliant because what the what
they did is they recruited a bunch of
professors like me who have experience
in producing online
courses
people who
have some drive have some interest and
they're offering us the chance to teach
whatever we want anything that we're
qualified to teach you can make a course
about it and it's sort of that you know
if if you build it they will come or or
not
so i i picked existentialism since i've
got all these videos
um available for it and there seems to
be a lot of interest in it
and i'm probably if this goes well i'm
going to keep you know developing new
classes for them
i'm expecting the
existentialism class to be up and
running and ready to enroll students
probably around the middle to the end of
march so it's coming up pretty quickly
and i've got a lot of work to to do in
in designing that because i'm a bit of a
perfectionist when it comes to to
coursework
it's probably going to cost
uh somewhere around 500 or 600 dollars
per student which for
college credit is actually pretty cheap
and the best part about it is
as opposed to my other classes where i'm
teaching for colleges where the college
is getting the bulk of the
the money oh plano gives the instructors
most of the the money so it offers us a
way to produce really cool classes
uh have students who really want to
study the material and be able to make a
decent living at it
if this if this takes off that may
become a full-time gig for me developing
classes and teaching classes for them
i'm
also still working on stuff for curious
i've uploaded a number of videos i just
need to actually produce the the lesson
material for those i'm a little bit
behind on that i'm going to start with
stuff having to do with plato's ion so
then i've got some some other some other
things in the work
i'm still doing some things with
learners everything on learnest of
course is free a lot of stuff i'm
curious is free if i have the time i'll
be doing some things for udemy and
for
teachers pay teachers developing
resources but i just haven't had the
time to get to that yet
been doing a bit of consulting work here
and there some of it basically along the
lines of coaching really what what you
do as a philosopher in the kind of line
that i'm in is practical reasoning and
we can do
what is nowadays called coaching because
it's been done for for millennia by by
people who you know were philosophers or
theologians or you know
all sorts of things it's applied for
practical reasoning and we bring to bear
the resources of classical and
contemporary philosophy so it's a bit
more rigorous and a bit more
insightful than your normal
coaching experience i've been doing uh
some work with
consulting in terms of critical thinking
um
and some in term i've got some
discussions going in terms of projects
and ethics
what else videos this has been a big
month for for shooting videos i've i
released some core concept videos on
john stuart mill
and on plato and i've decided to take
the advice of some of the people who had
been asking about this
i'm going to keep shooting videos on
plato
core concept videos and i'm going to
write a book i'm going to write an
e-book
and it's going to have the videos nested
within them and then a lot of discussion
about what's going on you know in those
texts
you know very thumbnail
uh outline boiled down
uh
you know to help people who want to
know some important things about plato
and hopefully steer them towards towards
uh
spending some time with with the tax but
even if they don't hopefully coming away
with some some
idea about what the guy is talking about
so i core concept videos i i shot some
existentialism videos this month some on
heidegger
some on rilke and i towards the end of
the month i got to shooting some stuff
on marcel which i was very happy about
i did one plato video an hour long
lecture on the ion
i got to do some new 10 shorts videos
i'm now soliciting
input
on a i'm using a video to actually do
that people put comments which are you
know questions or comments and then i
eventually bundle them together if they
have some sort of common theme and do 10
shorts i did the first of those
number 12 in the 10 short series this
month and i was i was quite happy with
it
um i'm going to still keep doing these
veloso geek
reflections on the technosphere
there's a lot of interesting things to
to think about i'm going to try to
actually shoot one of them this week
having to do with
our attention and and
the amount that we we ought to pay to to
things you know is there is there a sort
of obligation for us to pay attention to
to people's uh posts and
news articles and opinion pieces that
sort of thing
um
of course i'm shooting the religion in
america course and i did i did several
of those videos
this last month
i did a dr sadler philosophy forum you
know using the live feed i actually
meant to do a google hangout in air that
turned into a regular google hangout
because they're a little bit confusing
and that was a lot of fun
uh there were a lot of people who i got
to engage with and actually see face to
face which normally doesn't happen with
with
my my
subscribers and viewers
the google hangouts on air are really
designed to have like one or two or
three people on
basically like talking heads and have a
question answer interface
so we we did one of those uh this this
last uh weekend
uh and then finally
in january we kicked off this series
that i'm doing
monthly at the kingston public library a
historical building here in kingston one
of the the older cities in new york used
to be the capital actually at one time
and
the first lecture
it's the series is called glimpses into
existence and it's all about
existentialist
thinkers so the first lecture
brought up you know
the general structure
for the the year and talked about these
11 different thinkers who we're going to
be doing you know ranging from
kierkegaard all the way to gabriel
marcel with you know sartre and
heidegger and
kafka and dostoyevsky all in between you
know
um and we had some really great you know
discussion and question and answer i
talked about some of the basic themes
and from from this point on it's all
going to be
individual thinkers so i'll talk a bit
about that when i get to the video stuff
i guess the only other really important
thing about january
is that i
i and my wife
started going back to the gym again we
both want to
get in better shape and we started
cooking some
deliberately cooking some healthier
meals it's not that the stuff that we
cook is is not all that healthy because
we tend to cook from scratch anyway but
a lot of you know working with new
ingredients
uh and and trying to go to more whole
foods and lower the portions of meat you
know we're midwesterners so we we do
like our meat
and we like it in large portions but
we're trying to you know shrink the
portions have more fish eat more salads
you know and it's no fun to do that sort
of stuff unless you can make the food
taste really good so we've been doing
some some experimentation with you know
new recipes and and just you know trying
things out
so that's that's january now what's
coming up in february this is going to
be a very
packed month it's a short month
and you know losing those three days
really makes a big difference
like i said i'm teaching two classes
religion in america which i i'm shooting
uh videos for
uh which eventually will be an entire
sequence all indexed to a particular
textbook
and i'm not quite sure what i'll do with
with all that material later on but but
for the time being if you're interested
in following along with the class
lectures they're available to you i
usually release them anywhere from like
you know one to two days after i shoot
them
i'm not recording any new videos in my
ethics class because i've got everything
i need for that and i'm just having fun
engaging in a lot of discussions with my
my face-to-face students i'm going to be
this month i'm i'm spending a lot of
time developing that that existentialism
class with the player know
so
you know stay tuned about that there'll
be there'll be updates
uh when it's ready to go i'll put
updates on all my my social media and
i'll probably do a video talking about
the class as well
because i want to get a good batch of
students in for the trial run you know
and and uh if it really takes off well
this will become something like i said
that i'll i'll keep doing classes on
like it you know i i could see myself
doing a class just on aristotle's nika
mccann ethics
and
leading students through it and doing
something that normally isn't done in
classes on that which is to say
these passages over here in the politics
by the way they inform this these
passages over here in the on the soul
they inform this if you're confused
about this let's take a look at what's
going on in the eudaimian ethics let's
take a look at what's going on in this
passage over here in the rhetoric but
using the nick of mccain ethics as the
sort of
not to bring them together
i might do a class on the
origin of the seven deadly sins which
actually started out as eight capital
vices
and you know run through all of that and
look at different
uh thinkers and their approaches to them
because it's it's actually quite varied
anyway that's that's a vaplero takes off
first i got to get the existentialism
course
up running enrolled
underway and i'm just still doing the
prep work for that
i'm going to be releasing some curious
lessons this month
so those are a little bit those are like
bite size
you know 10 to 20 minute
lessons usually connected together in in
terms of a text
uh i'll be adding more material in
learners pretty much resources when i
shoot new videos that belong to courses
there like the existentialism videos i i
do that
as far as videos go i'm actually very
happy to report
that
just just last night we broke the 9 000
subscribers mark for this channel so
that's kind of big news next milestone
another thousand will be ten thousand
and this last month we passed the three
quarter of a million views of these
philosophy videos
it's really quite extraordinary
i guess there's a real hunger out there
for
for this kind of
this kind of video
i'm going to be shooting videos this
month i i've got some ambitious plans to
shoot a lot of videos on existentialism
because i need them actually for that
player no class so i want to shoot some
more marcel
i want to shoot a few things on sart if
i get the chance including no exit i
want to talk about the that play
i want to shoot some stuff on heidegger
um some of it's
you know
big overview stuff from being in time
some of it from his letter on humanism
which is a response to sartre i also
want to shoot some material on simone de
bouvoir
particularly the ethics of ambiguity
and i'm hoping that i can shoot some
material on kierkegaard's uh sickness on
to death so that's a lot already right
there
i'm going to keep doing core concept
videos on plato like i said i'm going to
just focus on those
but i'm not sure how many i'll release
we're going to be doing the class videos
from the religion in america class i'm
going to do at least one more of the 10
shorts
videos this this month if i get enough
questions maybe i'll consider doing more
i've got a few philoso geek reflections
that i want to try to shoot
and one of the things that i wanted to
get started last month that i didn't
actually get underway
was the sequence going through hegel's
phenomenology
that's got to start this month
some things conspired to keep that from
happening
i'm thinking that
maybe for the time being what i'll do is
try to get two of those done per month
so like one every two weeks
and
i'm just gonna you know i don't know how
long it's going to take me to get
through the entire phenomenology it
might take the entire year at that rate
but we're just going to focus in on on
each section
and try not to skip over anything
it's sort of like you know the history
of philosophy without any gaps except
it's just hegel's phenomenology without
any without any gaps
so i'm going to shoot some of those
hopefully uh beginning this week
got a lot of writing projects that i'm
working on this this month
i'm trying to write a paper for an
ethics conference on plato and what
exactly the virtues are and how they
work
um i'm editing a paper from a previous
conference
that i've got to get
revised and it's about anselm and
morality and god
i'm also writing another anselm related
paper
for the upcoming
saint anselm conference at saint
anselm's college in april
and i'm talking about anselm's views on
marriage and sexual desire
and
how it fits within to the matrix of his
thought
the conference is actually about
anselm's political thought but i'm doing
it on marriage and the family and sexual
desire and relations like that
um
and i'm also writing a talk that i'm
going to be giving later this month so
that that's a good segue into this this
last thing that i want to talk about
i've already done
my
dr sadler's philosophy forum for this
month so i don't anticipate doing
another one until
next month and i'll put that you'll see
it available
on my uh my facebook author page if you
subscribe to that or in my
google plus
events i i also put it in there
and i'll list it further ahead of time
and open up the q a app a bit a bit
earlier
i think it'll i'll still be doing
something something on plato
this time around
um
but i've got two other things going on
this month
and they're both towards the end of the
the month
one is
i'm going to be going out to salve
regina college where i've been invited
to give a talk to the honors students
and i think there may be a lot of other
people there in attendance as well
and the talk is my mandate is this i'm
supposed to talk about
nietzsche's
early work the birth of tragedy
and to
explain some of the key ideas and some
of why why it matters
to an audience
about which i should presume no previous
knowledge of nietzsche so that's that's
a fun challenge i've already got some
some ideas in in play about what i'm
going to talk about
um
you know that's the work where nietzsche
begins talking about the the dionysiak
and the apollonian and a lot of people
want to say yeah it's about this duality
within human beings and that's totally
not what nietzsche is saying
as a matter of fact he talks about a
third response and he says some things
over here might not be any of these
responses
um they're the you know the apollonia
and dionysiak are really hard to hold
together in a creative tension and
that's what the greeks managed for a
while and then it all fell apart uh in
part because of socrates and euripides
but also cultural
developments and so i'm going to talk
about about that and that's going to be
a lot of fun i'm really happy that they
invited me to go out and and give that
talk
and i'm hoping that this will be
the first of many times going going out
i've never gone to solve a regina i've
given talks
in this area and um
obviously at marist i've done some talks
the culinary institute of america have
done a few talks there uh felician
uh college i've done some talks there
i've gone to a few conferences here and
there like one at fordham and
and uh so i'm really looking forward to
getting to see a new school
uh
i already know some of the people there
i'm hoping to get to meet some some
other people there i always have a lot
of fun with these these kind of things
so that's that's going to happen by the
way that will be videotaped so if you're
you know you're not going to be able to
see it most likely unless you actually
are invited to the event but you will be
able to
see the footage of it
um
everybody is invited if you're in the
area to the second glimpses in existence
into existence
talk at the kingston public library
uh towards the towards the end of the
month
and that one is specifically focused on
kierkegaard so i'll be talking
for
you know about 45 minutes going over
some of the main themes
in kierkegaard's work
in his life
he died pretty young by the way
and
then you know there'll be some question
and answer and that's always pretty
lively
if you're not in the area and you'd like
or you know you can't make it
on a saturday
morning
it'll be available
uh in my youtube channel
uh probably a day or two after the talk
and
i'm organizing these into a playlist as
well as putting them into the
existentialism playlist
specifically devoted to this lecture
series by the way i will probably
continue doing
yearly you know month to month lecture
series
at the kingston public library so long
as i live in this area so next year i'll
probably pick a different theme
but for this year it is 11
existentialist writers
um i'm really enjoying this and having a
good time with with you know
digging back into these guys and
preparing these talks
so that's what's going on in february
that's what happened in january and
i hope all of you have a good month
and
you see another one of these coming up
in in march